hi everyone
this is steph from the bars with online
solution
at o9 we are digitally transforming
how businesses plan and operate today
i'm based out of amsterdam i'm running
online in europe
as well as our global go to market
practice today
we're going to talk about ai-powered
integrated business planning
on google cloud what is the agenda for
today
we'll start with a quick introduction
into online solutions
followed by the relevance of planning in
today's world
where we'll share a couple of learnings
from the pandemic
then we will talk about the architecture
of what we call the future ready
enterprise
followed by a couple of use cases in
retail
and manufacturing then we close out with
the key contacts
so that you can engage with us going
forward
what is online all about o9 is a premier
ai platform
for integrated business planning and
digital operations
we support companies in getting to a
more accurate forecast
a faster response and end-to-end
visibility
the online platform is designed for
fortune 500 companies
we're working with leaders in every
single industry
in retail think about walmart and
starbucks
where we help with forecasting
replenishment and integrated flow
planning
in consumer products companies like
nestle and abm bath
as well as estee lauder we support those
companies in
demand forecasting supply planning and
integrated business planning
over the last years the online platform
has been adopted
by many other leaders in different
industries like exxon mobil and oil and
gas
and t-mobile in telecom last but not
least
google is an online client we're
supporting
google consumer hardware in better
predicting demand
as well as doing the supply planning and
integrated business planning
why are so many of those fortune 500
companies selecting online
that is because we have developed this
next generation planning platform
that is able to cope with the complexity
of organizations
as well as using that technology to help
them
better planning then we have designed
and ui
ux that from an enterprise point of view
feels like your google device or your
google applications
and hence it is architected
to drive user adoption lastly
time to value is extremely important our
implementations
are short or fast and follow a very
agile
implementation methodology
what i want to do with you next is share
a couple of learnings
from this pandemic one have large
retailers and large manufacturers
experience throughout the past couple of
months
first the month variability it's all
about can i detect
better the risks and opportunities on
the demand side
what we have seen is those product mix
shifts
right an increase in essential products
but the
decrease in others channel shifts right
overnight
we went from the traditional brick and
mortar to online
we've also seen regional demand
variability with look down and reopening
schedules varying by
country by city in some cases by zip
code
so the question is many organizations
how do you now predict demand when all
of this
happens in a very short amount of time
that is a challenge
for many and that is something we
support global companies with
second is on the supply side again it's
all about
early detection many companies today do
not have
the visibility on the capacities
material availability
and lead times of their suppliers
co-packers or contract manufacturers
what we have observed is that supplies
and suppliers are slowing down or
stopping production
but some are coming back online so how
do i know
on which one i can rely on when right
then what we have seen is that
inventory and capacity visibility across
the network is challenging
there are multiple erps multiple systems
and they don't have that visibility
quickly enough and then lastly global
companies struggle with visibilities
into their supplier network so very
often
they do not know what suppliers can
commit
and what their capacities and material
availabilities are
third is integrated planning and
response
how fast is an organization able
to run scenarios the month can be 90 the
amount can be 100 the month can be 110.
well what is my supply chain response
what is my true cost to serve
and do i understand the different
assumptions that go into those different
scenarios
companies today lack the ability to run
fast scenario planning
understanding all the different
tradeoffs
including the financial ones again that
is something
where we provide support the other two
key learnings is that enterprise
collaboration
goes digital what we have seen is that
whether companies have production
planners or supply planners or demand
planners or commercial planners
overnight all of those functions had to
work from home
and what we've seen is that that boosted
online and digital
collaboration but also show the
possibilities
of looking into more centralized
and more specialized series that
companies can deploy
lastly what we've seen is digital
operating models for structural
transformation
cxos they want structural improvement
in both resilience and cost that means
that
digital collaboration doesn't stop
within the four walls of the enterprise
the question is how can we go beyond
that and start connecting with suppliers
and
customers in more real time use that
knowledge to then shape demand
and better collaborate with suppliers
and contract manufacturers
so we have observed a couple of key
trends a couple of key learnings
and we have definitely seen the need for
global companies
to digitally transform how they do and
execute
integrated business planning today
now what i want to do next is introduce
you
to the online platform and i would like
to do that by using an example from
google maps
in this example google is able to tell
us hey leave by 845
to arrive at the airport one and a half
hours before your flight
now we all take this kind of technology
for granted but to me it's a beautiful
example
of how we have moved from
sort of traditional data and data mining
to prescriptive decision making
now let's take this example to the
enterprise assume that we could sense
that the amount is going up
what do i instantly want to understand
can i satisfy that demand yes or no
if not then i want to understand why not
where my constraints
is it a factory constraint a material
constraint
a logistics constraint but it doesn't
need to stop there
what i truly want is a prescriptive
recommendation
like google maps is giving us here and
saying hey i
found out that we have this logistics
constraint
but no worries we can set up an expedite
lane
so you can fulfill that amount on time
oh and by the way
the additional cost of that expedite are
x
and that is the notion of digital
transformation
in the planning space in the enterprise
now what is actually behind this example
right that google maps is using
three core capabilities that will link
to the enterprise and to the online
platform in a second
in the middle you find something that we
call the ai-powered knowledge model
so in the google maps example right
there is network master data
think about the map with the roads and
the traffic lights and the speed limits
that is obviously connected with the big
data store what do we find in a big data
store
location tracking calendar information
and the flight status
all those data elements help us spotting
risks and opportunities much earlier
so now when you combine network master
data with big data
and you run smart algorithms now on your
mobile device
you can now receive prescriptive actions
right with predictive alerts and again
that is where
we need to take enterprise decision
making
so that that becomes as easy and as
prescriptive
as is example with google maps so sm9
we develop the following platform that
allows us
in the transformation to prescriptive
decision making
what you can see in the middle is what
we call an enterprise knowledge graph
the digital brain of the enterprise
that is allowing us to create a full
digital representation of the enterprise
from the supply chain the supplier nodes
the material hubs the factories to the
ship to's
connecting that with the different
demand notes the products
the initiatives the sales accounts all
the way to the go to market channels
whether it's selling through retail
business to business
or to you know stores or online
ultimately all the way down to the end
consumer
where we can also bring in data from the
competitor
so that entire knowledge brain is then
connected with various data sensors
what kind of data sensors think about
your erp
where we connect with master data and
transactional data
but more importantly we want to connect
with data that gives us insights in
risks and opportunities
so we can connect with external data
sources both structured and unstructured
from nature can i give a couple of
examples
absolutely think about a company like
abm bath
the largest beer company in the world
they're selling through retail
they're selling online and through
distribution what is driving their
demand
think about weather think about
competitive pricing
think about competitive promotions their
own trade promotions their marketing
initiatives
so what if we could collect all the data
and use that more intelligently
to forecast the demand other examples
starbucks
what is driving guard amount think about
local events
a football game or maybe a
graduation event when a starbucks store
is located
on a university campus again weather is
also a big influencer
in terms of what's driving the month at
starbucks so again it's about capturing
that information
and bringing that in is that only
happening with consumer products
not really think about companies like
pirelli tires
or bridgestone tires they are selling
tires to dealers and oems
what is driving their demand that could
be
you know the number of cars being
produced by the oems
can we incorporate that kind of data and
again the answer is yes
so the entire notion is we are looking
out for all those data sources
that can either predict a demand risk or
opportunity
or a supply risk opportunity and
integrate that with
the digital brain then on top of the
digital brain
is where we expose different planning
workflows
on the far left hand side it's all about
joint customer collaboration
as well as better connecting with my
account sales teams category management
and product portfolio management
then when i jump into the enterprise
again that is where my commercial teams
are connected
with my customers and that is where we
need to support them
with any operating planning initiative
planning
demand planning gap closure planning and
all that combined with analytics
because planning and analytics go hand
in hand on the same platform
that is where you can do supply chain
planning we are creating a full digital
twin of the supply chain
providing end-to-end visibility and
allowing for
smart and intelligent demand supply
matching
control tower capabilities and scenario
planning obviously
we want to connect that with suppliers
and contract manufacturers
as well as with all your factories and
logistics operators
then similar to the commercial side
planning and analytics go hand in hand
which means i can run analytics on my
cost to serve inventory
different planning policies and so forth
so
all this is then coming together in the
sales and operations planning
no more meetings in powerpoint it's
fact-based decisions
live in the platform where again the
system will prescribe
what actions to take based on running
the different scenarios
now all this is obviously across time
horizons
so from the daily planning you know the
next four weeks out
all the way to the long range planning
the next five years out
and that is a true differentiator of the
r9 platform
on top of that the entire architecture
has been built
to be open source which means that we
can integrate with r
python gerobi and the likes so that any
development that you have made in data
science already
can be leveraged in the online platform
what i want to do next is summarize what
we have discussed
09 it all comes together in this
enterprise knowledge graph
you should truly see this as the
intelligent brain
of your enterprise that is connected on
the left hand side
with your transactional backbone we
connect with your eup
system your crm systems your plm systems
and so forth
but also we have this integration
framework that i just mentioned
with our python grobe and the likes and
then obviously
at large-scale organizations like
walmart or like nestle or like abm bev
there is a need for being future proof
in terms of having big data capabilities
and that is where we are integrated with
hadoop and hive
on the right hand side you see that is
where all those different data sources
internal and external structured and
unstructured data
are coming into the brain row 9 takes
care of data cleansing and data
harmonization
ultimately we offer them this
best-in-class ui
through tablet browser mobile to the
different users
in the enterprise now obviously
o9 is born in the cloud and natively the
poor
deployed on google cloud and that is
also how we can scale
for and with our global clients
next are a couple of examples where has
online been implemented
and what is the value that we are
unlocking now first and foremost
google consumer hardware what happened
actually prior to unite
actually a legacy system in excel what
we identified was the supply chain costs
and inventory
were quite high uh as well as
there were complexities in managing the
end-to-end supply chain
now with the online platform google
consumer hardware
is able to make better decisions to
reduce inventory
and to reduce non-standard supply chain
costs such as you know flex capacity
expedites and so forth
at estee lauder we are replacing sap apo
at a global scale for the month planning
for supply planning
for integrated business planning one of
the unique
issues at st is that their product
portfolio changes very rapidly
and hence there is a need to better plan
for new product introductions
but also to link that to the supply
chain to minimize solvent risks
for products that you're going to take
out of the shelves
two other examples would be in the
retail space starbucks and walmart
what are we replacing at starbucks jda
plus a lot of spreadsheets
what was really the issue at starbucks
is that a barista in the store
is spending way too much time on
inventory on admin work on ordering
and starbucks wants that barista to
spend time with the client
the other issue is that there is a lot
of demand variability
driven by weather local events and so
forth
so what we did we actually built
an ai powered forecasting model taking
into consideration weather data
promotional data
external events data and predicting that
a month at skew store level
while at the same time linking that in
an automated fashion to the
replenishment
so that the barista can spend time on
serving you and me
rather than doing ordering and inventory
and so forth
at walmart we are deploying
a solution for integrated flow planning
in other words how do i take my products
from my inbound dc's to the shelf in a
most efficient and optimal way
taking into consideration all the
different constraints
the costs and the complexities of a
network that consists of a million skus
four and a half thousand stores and 200
plus dc's
prior to oni walmart was not able to run
a full constraint plan with widow 9 they
are
as well as they can run different
scenarios to understand trade-offs
between improving on-shelf availability
and cost
so what is the impact of online let me
give you two examples
at a large retailer where we implemented
the united platform
we were able to improve the forecast
accuracy
improve the service level in reality
reduce
expediting costs for both labor
and transportation another example would
be a large industrial manufacturing
company
where we implemented the month supply
and inventory
and we've seen tremendous improvements
in forecast accuracy
inventory reduction as well as in
significant improvement in service level
and a reduction in expediting and
transportation costs
so what we believe is that for every
billion dollar in sales
there is a 10 to 20 million dollar value
opportunity
when companies decide to implement
online
now if you want to hear more about
online about some use cases
or about anything else around our
platform
you can contact me directly or our
google
client account lead simon baxis
thank you very much and wishing you a
wonderful day